our friend alexandros mourinhos shared
this with us in the evening standard
up to 300 000 people facing
heart-related illnesses due to
post-pandemic stress disorder warned
physicians yes post-pandemic stress
disorder you may not have heard of this
yet but ppsd is a well-known uh and
established medical diagnosis since
oh probably early 2022 was my guess
um you know which is to say not yet this
thing doesn't exist post-pandemic stress
disorder so named to sound like
post-traumatic stress disorder and it
will have more or less the same acronym
with just one letter different um isn't
a thing yet um yeah it's boris johnson
we don't need to look at him
um
this
so ppsd post pandemic stress disorder
this could result in a 4.5 rise in
cardiovascular cases nationally because
of the effects of ppsd with those aged
between 30 to 45 most at risk they claim
there are of course other reasons to
expect a rise in
i think i got it oh really you got this
um
one of the symptoms of is it ppsd sure
is lyocarditis
yes
oh my god i mean this this
this article is just so insane here we
go you can you can keep my screen on
here zach
a senior vascular surgeon said i've seen
a big increase in thrombotic-related
vascular conditions in my practice
far younger patients are being admitted
and requiring surgical and medical
intervention than prior to the pandemic
i believe many of these cases are a
direct result of the increased stress
and anxiety levels caused from the
effects of ppsd
we also have evidence that some patients
have died at home from conditions such
as pulmonary embolism and myocardial
infarction
i believe this is related to many people
self-isolating at home with no contact
with the outside world and dying without
getting the help they needed
i mean maybe just like leave that there
it's so freaking obvious
but
epicycles are back baby
it's really extraordinary
that a piece like this
with a
newly made up medical condition
that
my guess is i don't know when the next
i don't even know what the equivalent of
the dsm is for physical conditions
actually or maybe it would go in the dsm
right um
and i don't know this is the uk does the
uk use the dsm i don't even know but the
diagnostic and statistical manual i
guess is what the dsm stands for has
updates every i don't know five to ten
years something like this and uh ptsd
made it into the manual at some point
and um if it's due for an update soon
i'll bet they forced this one in there
yeah and they then list as one of the uh
symptoms of it all of these heart
conditions thus putting
i don't know the cart before the horse
the symptoms of something else entirely
as diagnostic of this made-up thing that
they can then say oh look at all these
people who have suffered look at all of
the indirect effects of the coronavirus
well this is an indirect effect of the
coronavirus but it's an indirect effect
almost certainly of the coronavirus in
that it is almost certainly a large
number of these things are in effect of
the only treatment we are allowed to
talk about for the coronavirus
yeah
you can see if you're standing anywhere
other than where they expect you to
stand you can see that the point is the
conclusion
walk through the door and no matter what
the evidence
is that emerges the point is it's going
to be shoehorned into pointing at that
conclusion even if they've got to make
up disorders they're going to normalize
stuff you know kids have strokes too
really no really not no they don't
actually sorry no um i'm not saying
never but for god's sake on the side of
a bus um yeah this wasn't on the side of
the bus but this was in the sunday new
york times uh last last week the kids
section you know there's a special kids
section the sunday new york times it's
only available in print not available in
the electronic version so here
we have extra extra the new york times
read all about it editors note this
section should not be read by grownups
the vaccine is ready for you it's the
biggest news of all
that
is what the new york times wants to feed
the children at the moment this section
just for the children of the people who
are still daft enough to get the hard
copy of this paper into their homes on
sundays
is what they want the children to be
reading it
it's amazing and i have to say for
anybody who is still
toeing the party line on this
you need to check in
with your understanding of why
these vaccines are being recommended for
children healthy children
right
this is the strongest indicator that you
could get that this isn't about health
this isn't about um protecting children
from something it is about something
that has not been described to us yep
and the idea that they will go directly
to children through the new york times
especially in a section that nominally
nominally is not for adults to read this
section should not be read by grownups
well it says
right yes uh
it's um
[Music]
finally
finally finally kids between 5 and 11
can get the code vaccine
wow it's what you've all been waiting
for yeah
this does actually
raise a point that i just want to say in
passing i keep forgetting we have a
lighter can i just burn this
um
i am increasingly uh i watch my blood
pressure go up every time i hear
somebody use any version of the term jab
i have the feeling that this was
somebody's very clever branding
and that the idea is it's kind of fun to
say jab i i think it actually has a
longer history maybe in the uk maybe
nonetheless i would say
it a emphasizes the thing that of course
naturally people focus on for any
vaccination or shots is the needle thing
right um and so the point is oh you can
take it it's just a jab it's not so bad
it'll be over quick right and the point
is no this has nothing to do with that
this has to do with the immunological
consequences and other consequences of
the stuff in
that
syringe and so right but but you can
specifically get into kids heads this
way like oh honey i know you're scared
of needles right it's gonna be fine
right we'll get you a lollipop
afterwards i would just
ask that people who are anywhere near
wanting to do an honest first principles
investigation of
what the costs and benefits and risks
that are associated with this anybody
who is in that group proper skeptics
need
staying in your lane
is saying jab right getting out of your
lane involves using any one of a number
of perfectly responsible synonyms that
are available to you right you could
call it a shot you can call it an
inoculation how about calling it getting
stuck
i i would like to stay out of that i
mean i agree but i would like to stay
out of that territory and just say that
the point is who's bidding are you doing
when you say jab right you're making it
cute
right if there's one thing this is even
if you think this stuff is great and all
of those of us who have our doubts are
out to lunch the point is it's still
serious business one way or the other so
uh
jab
it's it's the wrong term
[Music]
you